hello world in today's video I will show
you how to perform basic operations on
DynamoDB tables meaning saving getting
updating and deleting items on the table
we are going to perform basic operations
in DynamoDB tables from lamda using the
AWS SDK so I would not get into how his
Dynamo works on what is dynamo but I
will just go straight into the code and
show you how you can get this done as
always building everything as
infrastructure as code from the
serverless framework so let's go to the
code so let's get started as always
making a new directory and getting into
the directory we are calling this
service dynamo basic operations and we
get into the directory then we just
initialize the MPM package MPN in it -
yes then we initialize the serverless
project so let's create - t
AWS there's no GS - N and then we put
the name of the project so that we don't
need to change it in the service llamo
exchange for us now we open atom we are
going to do some modifications and then
we are going to create our dynamo table
so the first modification we already
have the name in place I'm going to
remove a lot of comments they are
distracting
then I adding my profile because I have
many and OSHA's use my default profile
and I will click the region that is
Ireland but you can pick any region you
like my default is not Virginia then we
are going down into the rulers llamo and
we are just going to define the database
using cloud formation I have done this
many times and basically we are defining
a table and we are using environmental
variables if you want to know more about
environmental variables leave me a
comment below and I can make a video out
of it but for now we're just using
environmental variables and I'm creating
them into several sgml so we can access
them from the code and from the
surveillance camera so I create a custom
variable and then I added here my
Berman's property in the provider and
refer to these custom settings that we
just created then the next step is to
define permissions for this table and we
are going to define the permissions
where the I am role comment is and we're
replacing it and we're defining forget
to put update and delete items in this
table so the lambda can do that after
that we are going to create some new
functions so I'm going to create one
function for each of the things we want
to do you can have everything in one one
function or you can have it separate
functions if you want to know more about
this you can go and check my video on
patterns but for now I will make it easy
and I will make one function pair
operation one function for save one
function forget our information for
delete and one function for update I
leave you card for the pattern video
after we have the four functions I'm
just going to save this file and go into
the Hudler and then here I'm going just
to clean up a bit we are going to create
a function that will be generated over
response because we're just returning
always a status code and a body so way
to repeat that everywhere and then I'm
going to create a new file that will be
the database manager will I will be
performing all the operations you see
the AWS SDK I create that file I go into
and I will start defining all the
functions and here is the beef of this
video first thing we want to do is to
require the AWS SDK and the module
document client then I will define the
table name it's a constant in this
module and that's referring to the
variable we have defined in the server
loose llamo again environmental
variables if you want to do more just
leave a comment below I could make a
video about these and then I create the
save function the get function the
delete function and the update function
and you will see that in each of these
there is more or less the same structure
there is parameters
area where we will define different
things in all the cases we have the
table name because we need to know in
which table we are playing the case I'll
say we have the item that is the one
that we just want to save the whole item
on the table name in the case of get and
delete we have the table name and also
we have the item ID that is the
reference to this item we want either to
get or to delete and in the case of
update the parameters will be more
complex these parameters will be sent to
the AWS SDK a lot dynamo Morial either
we have dynamo dot put dynamo dot get
remote delete dynamo dull update and
they will all take the parameters
I'm always permissive fiying these calls
so this is a promise so I'm doing that
promise after all of these calls for the
update let's stop for a moment and
analyze the whole thing because I think
is the most complex of all of them so
the update it takes three parameters the
item ID a Perriman parameters name
parameters value and then it returns the
new modified item so the parameters that
we need to construct this variable
called parameters the table name as in
our cases the key that is the item ID
and then we will take set of other
things first it will take a condition
expression this is not necessary but I
like to add it in the case so if the
attribute exists with this item ID if we
can continue if not it will throw an
error of the update expression and here
we define what is the parameters that we
want to change what is the attribute in
the table we want to change in this case
is a flexible one is dynamic so we pass
that in the matter and I will put set
params name that will be whatever we
decide to pass in this method and it
will be setting it to some value the
value is also dynamic and you can find
it in the expression attribute values
that we define the dynamic value and
then we have the return values that we
want to return all the new you can
change these for for our options these
are the old and all new and old as well
you can check the documentation for the
AWS SDK I will link it in the
in the comment box below for you to
check and then after we have these four
operations so we can go back to our
Handler and do the calls that we want to
do from these operations so we are going
to create our four methods that are
going to handle these functions first we
want to generate the item ID so for that
we need to use this library call ID so
we just install it in our dependencies
and then we can use it I will use that
in the save so we have a dynamic item ID
whenever we save because in nine more
items needs to be identified with a
unique ID so we should not have
duplicates so now I have the save item
and I will just fetch the item body that
it will be passed in the API gateway
body in the request body and then I'm
attaching to that item that we get from
the body the item ID that we are
generating with this library and then
I'm passing that item to the database
manager that save item and I'm returning
in the callback the response with this
item ID which has created and 200 for
the gate item is similar we are getting
the item ID for the path parameters and
then we are passing that item ID to the
database manager did they get item and
this item that we get I returning it in
the response to the API gateway so the
client can see it for delete we have a
similar one we are getting the item ID
from the path parameters but we are just
returning the item was deleted because
the response in this case will be empty
if everything goes fine
here we are not handling errors so in
the case that the item is not fine
we are just not doing a catch so that's
something you need to handle in your
case for example if you get an item that
doesn't exist it will return you on
empty response because we are not
handling the errors so remember that
these are
only for the happy path but this is an
example for you to see and for the
update it's a little bit more complex we
are getting the item item from the path
parameters and then the param name and
the param value from the body because
this will be a put so we will have a
body and then we are passing those three
things to our update item but we'll
return the new item updated and we will
pass that back to our response and
that's all the code we need now we can
go and deploy and after it is deploy we
can test it in postman so I will speed
this up for you so we go to testing so
when this is deploy we get our four
endpoints that are more or less the same
they just have different method and then
we can take them to postman and start
playing with them so we put our first
one that is to post and we create a body
that is very flexible because we have
not defined anything so we just passed
whatever we want I just pass a name for
example and then we can pass some
attribute one attribute to and things
like that this is an example so it's not
important what is in the in the item
just mashing that you have something
that makes sense for you and then after
we have this body we can just send it
and we will get an ID back this idea we
can use in the gate so we can now run
the get that is the same URL but it has
just a path parameter at the end that is
this idea that we just cut so I modify
the call and I send it and then we get
the item back with the ID and all the
attributes we can update this item and
we are going to change some attribute
for example attribute 1 we are going to
change and we are passing a new value
for that attribute and then we send it
and then we will see that the response
now has these that you would want to be
attribute 1 underscore near so that
change will do I get again of this will
get exactly the same because this was
saved in the database now
we can delete if it's just delete then
the item was deleted underneath we do I
get we are going to get an empty
response because this is returning from
the database an error and we are not
handling errors so the code as always is
available in github for you to take a
look that was the video for today I hope
you liked it if you did give a big
thumbs up if you have any questions
comments requests you can always leave
it in the comment box below